in fact there's so many rail cards that
they should just say okay we're going to
get rid of all rail cards am i going to
give middle-aged men
a white bastard middle-aged man's rail
card which means you've got to pay 33
extra because i mean everybody except
the middle age gets a bloody rail car
nowadays
you've been looking at transport a lot
recently what have you learned yes sorry
sorry okay so the book's coming out on
thursday it's being launched on on
thursday and it's called a transport for
humans are we nearly there yet and it's
co-authored and i have to say he's
probably authored rather more than i
have um by my colleague pete dyson who
was my colleague in the behavioral
science practice in ogilvy and now works
for the
department for transport as the head of
behavioral science there
and it's a very very interesting uh area
for exploration because
transport even more than most areas of
kind of business governmental behavior
tends to get dominated by reductionist
metrics
and as a result
it gets over optimized around what you
can easily measure things like speed and
time and capacity and duration and
punctuality
and under-optimized around things that
humans care deeply about but which you
can't actually measure because we don't
have quantifiable si derived units what
like
enjoyment regret
fairness okay there's a very useful
actually a guy called um i was going to
say chris rock but he's obviously not
called chris rock um there's a guy
called david rock who's a neuroscientist
he's a kiwi but based in new york and he
has a model which he calls scarf
and scarf stands for status certainty
autonomy relatedness and fairness
now i don't think it's a complete list i
think there are other things like regret
avoidance although you could put that
under certainty i suppose
but his contention is these are five
things that humans have evolved to care
deeply about but which economists
or for that matter transport planners
don't really understand or factor into
their equations at all so i'll give you
a very simple example okay um
and daniel kahneman has actually done
work around this it's much more annoying
to miss a train or a flight by five
minutes than it is to miss a flight by
25 minutes or half an hour or an hour
um now
you know to a you know reductionist
metric it shouldn't matter because you
missed the plane you didn't miss the
plane the degree of annoyance and upset
you might experience should be pretty
much exactly the same in either case
there's also much more regret i think if
uh if the flight was delayed and left
five minutes before you arrived at the
airport it pisses you off more than if
the flight wasn't delayed there are all
sorts of interesting psychological
things going on here
now the point about that kind of thing
is that for instance
barriers like cues at ticket machines
and you know problems getting through
ticket barriers or a delay at a gate
prior to boarding a train are likely to
create disproportionate annoyance
because they cause a large number of
people to miss a train by a very narrow
amount of money narrow amount of time
another thing would be
which is a particular rant of mine uh
you know they spent you know hundreds of
millions on new rolling stock for
timberslink
now thameslink because it's a
penetrating service you know it'll go
from places like brighton to bedford for
instance
it is potentially although it's mostly
used probably for commuter rail it is
potentially quite a long distance rail
service
and the trains by the way are very very
good i think they're extremely well
designed with one extraordinary failing
there aren't seat back tables
so if you're on a one and a half hour
journey from let's say brighton to i
don't know
just north of london
kentish town or something okay you can't
work on the train
okay now that kind of thing
everybody is basically
stipulating their and their assessing
transport proposals
based on their objective characteristics
of time and speed and capacity
and yet that's based on the assumption
that time spent on a train is a
dis-utility and that's in fact the
justifiable that's the case used to
justify high speed too
that everybody on a train is
economically useless so the less time
they spend on a train the more
productive these people are as opposed
to can we make their experience on the
train facilitate productivity yeah
so i mean interestingly they spent six
billion on high speed one and on the the
high speed rail line between folkestone
and some pancreas not necessarily a dumb
thing to do i'm not totally disputing
the value of that by any means
but they spent 6 billion
speeding the trains up between paris and
london
um and it was only something like 12
years later they put wi-fi on the trains
now the wi-fi on the trains okay i
imagine i'd let me get this i i'm gonna
guess here but i'm guessing it cost
either single-digit millions or maybe
low double-digit millions of pounds to
install that it might even even have
been less okay
but in many ways to any business person
thinking how do i get from central paris
to central london
that is probably more of a decider
relative to air travel
than the duration of the journey
because one significant difference
between the eurostar and flying to paris
or brussels or even amsterdam actually
is yes it takes longer but it's quality
time
you know you're sitting in the same
place with some sort of table for an
uninterrupted period of two or three
hours
they slightly do interrupt it by making
breakfast to be honest a little bit too
much of a drawn out
procedure for my tastes but nonetheless
it's three hours of time when you can
work read a book watch a film do exactly
what you'd be doing if you're at home to
be absolutely honest okay with the
additional facility of a pleasant view
out of the window
i mean i find train journeys
disproportionately productive yep i
agree and yet
most people actually you know i enjoy
the trip to manchester two hours ten is
about the right length for a train ride
you know it's not long enough to get
bored and it's long enough to actually
get deeply into something and be a bit
productive so these these reductionist
metrics which effectively treat humans
as though they were freight
in other words they turn transport into
a logistics problem
which is a psychology-free problem
actually logistics isn't quite
psychology free because you have the
state of mind of the recipient or the
sender to consider and so for example
online package tracking is actually a
transformation for ups or fedex because
you know many many people might not be
that bothered about a parcel arriving a
day late provided they know what's
happening
whereas if your package doesn't arrive
on friday as promised
and you don't have online package
tracking your natural assumption is it's
got lost not that it's got delayed well
i guess so actually even in the case of
freight there's a degree of psychology
but at least the freight itself doesn't
have a hissy fit because it's sent by
fedex not ups it doesn't have a hissy
fit because it's got to share the lorry
with some unsavory characters you know
okay freight is beautifully inert and
free of those psychological factors
whereas human passengers status
certainty autonomy relatedness fairness
really really matter yeah i guess as
transport becomes faster we have less
headroom to improve the speed of it so
you need to look at these other things
convenience enjoyability
i think we're hitting the law of
diminishing returns that's one point the
second thing is i think there are a lot
of metrics where we continue to pursue
things let me give you an example okay
there is a correlation between
punctuality and passenger happiness
i'm absolutely confident of that okay
however i think if you disaggregate the
data you'll find that that correlation
mostly emerges because people who are on
a transport journey that is
significantly delayed are very very
upset
i don't think there's much difference in
passenger satisfaction if your train
arrives on time or if your train arrives
four minutes late okay i regard it as
monstrosity that railway operators are
fined for rolling into a london terminus
more than three minutes after the
scheduled time is that right
yeah it's crazy now don't get me wrong
there are cases where punctuality
matters where people have to make a
connection for example and if you dick
around too much with the timetable it's
also punctuality is important for the
efficient running of the service because
obviously you if you run to timetable uh
you know it's likely that there are
knock-on effects on other trains i'm not
being totally ignorant of the importance
of the logistical challenge here but
from a pure passenger point of view no
one traveling into london and arriving
at a london terminus has failed to leave
10 or 15 minutes margin of error for
their onward journey okay you know i
mean if you're significantly pissed off
because the train is four minutes late
either your swiss or your borderline
neurotic and i would argue that's your
problem not the rail operator's problem
you really should have built in some
sort of buffer because let's be honest
if you've chosen any other mode of
transport most of all the car
you know if you drive into central
london by car you have to leave 50
minutes as a margin of error
you know so the idea that a train is
being disappointing if it's three
minutes late it's really getting a bit
silly did you have a look at the
reliability and the punctuality of
different modes of transport
yeah i mean
it is interesting in that
first of all what is punctuality so a
train that's late where the driver gives
information and reassurance to the
passengers probably creates a lot less
disquiet than a train that just stops in
the middle of the countryside for no
readily discernible reason for 20
minutes you know a train that keeps
moving slowly is less frustrating to
passengers than a train that grinds to a
halt you i i don't know if you drive a
car you're young so you excellent yeah
oh you're in manchester aren't you
anyway newcastle but i'm in texas right
now yeah oh where are you in texas
austin
oh what a glory you definitely drive a
car then yes um but the point i'm making
is that you know quite often as a car
driver you might choose a route home
where you keep moving even if the
journey is 10 minutes longer oh man this
is me this is me to a t exactly this is
me i know the roots home where i'm going
to get snilled up and i would prefer to
continue to move even if it's longer and
if it's further but i would prefer to
take that route because the
psychological discomfort of sitting in
traffic of having to do nose to tail
i can't sit on cruise control i can't
just sort of zone out a little bit and
continue to go yep all over it i mean i
mean if you've got slow moving traffic
adaptive cruise controls and absolute
joy isn't it because you just outsource
your driving to the bugger in front
you know you basically go okay i'll set
my speed at five miles an hour faster
than that guy and i'll just let him make
all the decisions
glorious
yeah it's like a conga line like a conga
line of people trying to get home from
work
i'm very interested in the psychology of
elect i've just bought an electric car
actually
and i find it very interesting how it
changes the psychology of driving
one of which is that range anxiety
probably
might have beneficial effects on
people's style of driving because they
it makes it more salient the extent to
which their style of driving impacts on
the number of miles that they get per
kilowatt
uh-huh so you're going to accelerate
less less harshly you're going to break
less harshly yeah yeah but secondly i
think there's an interesting thing in
that it makes you a nicer person in that
if the guy in front of you breaks
unnecessarily regenerative braking makes
you less resentful of your loss of
kinetic energy
because instead of thinking that guy's
just robbed me of my hard-won kinetic
energy you tend to think oh well i've
just squirted a bit of electricity back
into the tank as it were what are you
driving and so so it's a ford mustang
machi right i'm a bit of a lover of
american metal i have to admit and the
tesla to me is one fantastic car but
it's a bit too silicon valley it's a bit
i want a bit of detroit you know in
there that admittedly the mustang's
actually made in mexico but nonetheless
it has it's a little bit of americana
which i rather like actually and it's a
lovely gorgeous car to drive really
fantastic hasn't it been fascinating
watching what's happened to the entire
world's interpretation of electric
vehicles almost exclusively on the
shoulders of elon musk
like that that company to me seems to
have think about prius's
five years ago think about what it meant
to drive a prius and now think about the
entire category
of electric vehicles
i think yeah i mean i think there are
those strange entrepreneurs aren't there
who can where
there are certain products which are in
a sense they are their own advertising i
mean the iphone was a similar thing
and the reason i refer to products as
their own advertising is that not
necessarily because people automatically
want them
but there is this effect which is that
there are certain technologies which
once experienced you never go back
and that always fascinates me actually
that it's an interesting marketing
challenge when you have a product which
people don't necessarily want it to
begin with
but once they've had it they never
revert
and the mobile phone is a classic case
now you're too young to remember a
period where people were cynical about
mobile phone ownership but i experienced
10 years of that where i'm on in 1989 i
used a brick sized mobile phone on
oxford street not my fault i wouldn't
have done it to make a call but someone
rang me and people shouted abuse it
passed at me from parks and cars someone
actually ran down the window of a black
cab and shouted wanker out of the window
one second i just gotta
oh [ __ ]
hello
i'm on the podcast but where are you
see you shortly no problem fantastic
okay bye-bye bye-bye
um
and um
so i mean there is this electric car
thing that you drive in a slightly zen
way i i had in my previous car which was
an internal combustion engine car i had
adaptive cruise control
now apparently and i don't understand
this by the way but apparently once the
sufficient number of cars on a highway
have adaptive cruise control
it has highly beneficial effects
on the transit speed of all traffic
and i think i think i know what the
reason is okay which is that
when you have adaptive cruise control
if you're following a car let's say 100
yards behind
the adaptive cruise control is a much
better judge of distance and of the
car's deceleration
than your human binocular vision is
and therefore the your car slows down
gradually when the car in front slows
down
which means that you don't get this
weird breaking wave because you use your
brake lights less effectively what's
fascinating apparently is a braking wave
travels backwards
in
along a motorway uh something like it's
great it's on like 500 miles an hour
okay
so so if you could actually get three
cars just to break really dramatically
on a highway
and you could cause unwittingly a kind
of serious traffic jam and bottleneck uh
basically four miles behind you
something like 10 seconds later
there are these extraordinary effects
going on in the fluidics of motorway
driving and for some reason if you
inject enough cars onto the highway with
adaptive cruise control and you get the
drivers to use them
use it
uh then actually it improves uh traffic
efficiency traffic flow efficiency quite
markedly even though a large number of
people either don't have it or don't use
it
one other thing i noticed i'd be
interested in your opinion because
you're in austin which would which would
give a good sample size
i've never been pissed off
as far as i can remember by anybody
driving an electric car
now i've never been cut up
they've never tailgated me okay you know
there are certain brands of cars and we
won't name them because ogilvy does the
advertising for some of them okay but
there are certain brands of cars where
the owners are disproportionately
tailgaters
left lane undertakers you know
i mean it used to be bmw and it isn't
really anymore to the same extent but
bmw drivers used to have that
characteristic i think it's moved on to
other brands now
and what interests me is there are now
quite a few teslas i mean it's a very
you know it's selling in very large
numbers
but i've never had an unpleasant act of
behavior from a tesla driver how much of
that is the selection effect of the
people that buy teslas and how much of
that is the type of vehicle we've got to
remember demography this is not a
representative sample because people who
buy cars from new which is most people
buying tesla's at the moment are
disproportionately older and richer
but equally there was objectionable
behavior from new
you know certain german car brands
which were also new
so you you may be right the the tesla
particularly appeals to a particular
mindset of person who isn't an [ __ ]
to begin with
um but i've never i've never had an
electric car piss me off i think
now maybe to be honest this might be
[ __ ] but on the other hand in my own
behavior i have noticed a kind of more
zen style of driving emerging have you
found yourself more aligned and awakened
as soon as you get into your mustang
mackey oh well it's i'm practically too
messing mate i love it absolutely love
it um yeah i have to say it's been an
absolute joy can you see yourself ever
going back to uh internal combustion
engine no no in fact more than that now
admittedly there are tax advantages i
ought to mention this so it's not it's
not a complete apples for apples
comparison but we need to replace my
wife's car and we've basically gone with
the electric mini because the act of
owning now logically you should say one
electric car one petrol car but actually
the act of owning a um
an electric car first of all has largely
banished range anxiety
okay so that actually i don't yet have a
charger at home i'm still fiddling
around getting a seven kilowatt charger
at home uh installed and yeah i just
want to say to your listeners if you do
live somewhere now london might be a bit
of an exception but if you live
newcastle manchester somewhere you know
which is a sane size city not a stupidly
sized megalopolis okay
um
uh you can get by perfectly well without
uh particularly if you're a little bit
nocturnal like me um you can get by
perfectly well without a home charger in
fact assuming your mileage isn't insane
presumably you could use the same
charger for your
mustang as you could use for the new
mini as well do they have the same
connection exactly that yeah so it'll be
it'll be a type two charger seven
kilowatt and we might even we don't know
if we at the house we're in we've got
three phase power so we could even get
two 11 kilowatt charges if we wanted to
go a bit flash so he was an interesting
thing we're both buddies with rob
henderson and i remember
uh probably about three years ago rob
i mean all of that guy is fantastic dude
he is yeah anybody that's not following
rob henderson on twitter now search rob
k henderson he is fantastic to follow um
he
tweeted ages ago saying that one way you
could encourage the adoption of electric
vehicles would be to give a state a
signal that was visible by everybody so
for instance the mini is a good example
of this the fact that you look at an
electric mini and you can't actually
tell unless you're a real car buff and
you know that the yellow detailing
we've got the green number plate yes the
green number plate so the grid
the green number plate thing is now in
the uk it's a status symbol i am driving
an eco-friendly car this is electric
zone and so forth i wonder
soon
if that green number plate if people are
going to want to revert back to no
longer having that to have it as they
don't want it to be this outward show of
how much they care about the environment
that i'm so cool so they'll counter
signal the new signal well well you're
not only are you right but i can prove
you're right because there was research
done on
tesla's sorry don't there was research
done on priuses
versus if i'm right there was a
alongside the toyota prius there was a
honda hybrid
and the toyota prius was suey generous
it was obviously a hybrid
whereas the honda something or other was
effectively a stealth hybrid
okay it was a little like you know a
kind of um i mean there are quite a few
models i think there's a range rover or
land rover isn't there which is a
plug-in hybrid um
and what they did find was that in i
think in democrat areas
people i mean vastly more people bought
the prius than bought the um the stealth
hybrid but then in certain more
right-wing areas
there was an urge for people to enjoy
the cost savings of driving a hybrid
vehicle without in fact telegraphing
that fact to their neighbors or to
fellow motorists that's funny i i'll try
and dig out the paper but there was some
research done on signaling and counter
signaling if you like and it is very
interesting because you know one of the
best things people could do
really okay to improve their
environmental impact or to reduce their
environmental impact will be either
replacing their home central heating or
boiler in the case of the uk
um or indeed replace the boiler with a
heat pump
but it's worth noting that unlike a car
a heat pump doesn't really carry the
same bragging rights or status
connotations you can't drive the heat
pump around the center of london no no
you can't drive and i don't think
anybody's pulled by having a heat pump
yeah yeah don't worry about the fact
that i'm still driving a diesel vehicle
wait until we get home and you see my
heat just wait wait julia get home love
and see my heat
actually i didn't even i'm okay now i
like you know i like to consider myself
reasonably you know um scanny in terms
of physics and general science but even
i can't quite get my head around a heat
pump because apparently a heat pump is
500 efficient
okay so the best boiler you can have
converts energy heat energy from gas
into heat energy in your home um at
around about the 90 efficiency level
maybe it's a little bit higher so in
other words you know they now recapture
far more of the heat that used to escape
into the into the environment um
and i think some of them might even i
think there was one boiler i heard about
which had a kind of sterling engine
operating so it generated a bit of
electricity on the on the exhaust gases
but you can get 95 efficiency what i
never realized is a heat pump we all
understand how a fridge works right okay
it basically uses some energy to
extract energy from one place and put it
somewhere else okay
now of course
the problem there is that
we tend to think when it's cold outside
generally heat pumps work well in
countries like the uk and where you
don't get extremes of temperature by the
way so you know austin texas the case
may be slightly weaker
over here you need you need a vest and
shorts during the day and you need a
hooded top and long trousers on a night
time the amount of heat swing in the
middle of november is absolutely insane
ah but there's a great thing for that
which is true of phoenix as well which
is you have a great nightlife because
it's intolerable going out during the
day so everybody goes out in the cool of
the evening correct and you get totally
hot you know i always notice that about
phoenix you actually get a bit of late
night life
you know which is rather fun because
people then go and do the kind of one
spanish style wandering around the
street stuff like kind of eight or nine
at night the thing as well is especially
at this time of year where it is it's
perfectly fine during the day it's not
disgusting during the day you're talking
23 degrees maybe ish at celsius during
the day outside so all of those places
that have got beer gardens with food
trucks that are pulled up outside
they've managed to pivot themselves so
i'm across the street from a place
called cosmic coffee and beer garden now
if that's not just a perfect display of
the fact that you've got daytime and
nighttime they have this unit they've
got fairy lights that aren't used during
the day they've got a beautiful garden
and a waterfall in there and then on the
night time all the lights come on
everything dims the music comes out live
stage goes on and you think this is a
single unit that's got every use under
the sun from 9am for breakfast when i
went this morning until 1 in the morning
it's amazing
there is a guy in australia who worked
out that that you could have a dual
purpose coffee shop and cocktail bar
and i mean i imagine using digital
signage you could you could actually
effectively
branding even more yeah yeah you could
you could morph a retail outlet from one
thing to the other yeah because you know
the kind of lighting and signage that's
appropriate for a tea shop
isn't really appropriate for a you know
you know cocktail bar or whatever yeah
so you could i'm sure using clever leds
and lighting and screens uh do something
really clever there but i i i've always
slightly fantasized about austin um
because
i'm a little bit hipster and a little
bit redneck yeah um and so i've always
rather like the idea that i can go to a
farmer's market in the morning and buy
organic sourdough bread that's
handcrafted by people with really
interesting body art but then if i
wanted to i could drive a pickup truck
out into the desert and fire machine
guns and oil drums you know and the fact
that that kind of yin and yang thing
really kind of appeals to me you really
feel it here here's another thing i was
thinking about to do with transport so i
was talking where was i driving i can't
remember where i was driving maybe up to
edinburgh and google maps you don't have
the same number of preferences as i
think humans want and there's two
preferences that i would want to have
included in google maps the first one
would be ease
so that would be can i sit at a more
consistent speed throughout the entire
journey i.e can i sit on cruise control
my car doesn't have radar-guided cruise
control or adaptive cruise control so
can i sit at just a single speed or
close to a single speed for the most
amount of time and also the fewest
number of turns the fewest number of
junctions the straightest road i don't
want to go on some b road for ages and
then another option that i would love to
have in there would be beauty so can i
drive let's say that i don't actually
care about the speed of my journey i'll
go a bit further than that which is the
google maps and actually i'm fairly sure
that the great guy jonathan height his
sister is involved in a campaign to make
google maps more public transit friendly
all right and one of the american
aspects of google maps it doesn't really
understand multi-modality
so if i say to google maps i want to get
to work okay
it will either think that i'm only going
to use public transport which as an
american means i don't own a car and it
will suggest i catch a bus to the
station
which you know
which takes bloody ages okay and then
take a train into london because that's
public transport
or it suggests i'd drive all the way
into central london which you would only
do if you're a lunatic now an electric
car i don't even pay the congestion
charge but to be honestly honest you
don't need the congestion charge anymore
they should pay me for the stress of
driving into bloody london because it's
intolerable you know the speed limit
changes from 20 to 30 more or less at
random bus lanes spring up all over the
place there are cycle lanes which take
up half the available space you know if
you don't basically kill someone or or
get a 50-pound fine you count yourself
lucky and then then we're going to add
electric scooters into the mix and it's
going to be you know good night vienna
frankly okay
but google will either suggest i drive
in which is mad or that i get a bus to
the station now what we all do as brits
is we drive to the station we park the
car we take a train but google maps
can't get its american head around that
multi modality
and you're right i mean interestingly
when i do drive to the station i drive
to quite often just a station called
oxford where it's slightly easier to
park and it's a little bit cheaper to
park but the main reason i do this quite
often oddly and it seems completely
bonkers okay
is that i can't deliberately catch a
slower train to london blackfriars the
fast way to get to work is seven oaks
london bridge change to thames link
thames link brett fries okay or
what sorry this is really boring to your
international audience waterloo east go
through southwark tube station walk to
black friars those are the two fast ways
to do it now what i do is i take a slow
stopping train that takes an hour rather
than 33 minutes
from oxford all the way to black friars
because it's one hour first of all it's
not very crowded the train so i can work
on the train
i get a table because i sit at the back
okay and it's an hour of total quality
time in which i can clear my email inbox
for the day now if i take the faster
route i have to change trains dick
around go down an escalator and so
you're absolutely right that transport
apps are all optimized around speed
not scenicness
sometimes they're optimized around price
okay but they're principally optimized
around one or two metrics which fail to
capture things that really really matter
to the human passenger i'll get do okay
how many of you listeners to the podcast
live in the uk
so this is okay if you ever want to go
to cornwall particularly if you want to
go to devon or you want to go to bristol
from london okay
there are trains non-stop from waterloo
to bristol temple meads and from
waterloo to exodus and david's okay
if you search
even if you search waterloo to exodus
and david's on the national rail website
these trains do not show up because
they're so speed obsessed they say go to
paddington on the tube take a fast train
to exeter from paddington
now a consequence of this is that
virtually nobody knows these exeter
trains exist
because if you search for them the only
way you can find them is to go exit is
to go waterloo to exodus david's and
then traveling via salisbury okay now
unless you're a kgb officer
you know looking to kill somebody
nobody's actually searched for that
journey you know in the last 10 years
okay
and no one's put in via sallspring
when you do put in via salisbury it
reveals these trains which are slow
but it's extremely beautiful as a
journey
and because nobody can find the trains
they are insanely cheap
because yield management basically
assumes there's no demand for that
service and the reason there's no demand
isn't because nobody wants it it's
because nobody knows that the choice
exists because the the algorithm has
basically hidden it from view yeah yeah
yeah i think my daughter my daughter and
three friends had to go to some weird
festival in cornwall because that's what
young people do
and i think i got something bonkers like
all four of them now admittedly they
have their you know young person's
bloody rail card in fact there's so many
rail cards that they should just say
okay we're going to get rid of all rail
cards and we're going to give
middle-aged men a you know white bastard
middle-aged man's rail card which means
you've got to pay 33 extra you know
because i mean everybody except the
middle age gets a bloody rail card
nowadays anyway sorry the
old boomer grumbled over i'll leave that
i'll leave that for a second
okay but i think i got them with their
rail cars it was like a first-class
single
um from waterloo to
exeter
for something like 20 quid each or 19
quid each in first class and i said look
i can send you a second class for 12
pounds 50. but i mean for the sake of
eight quid what the hell you know i had
i was in rome recently i'm not sure if
you've ever seen this before italian
trains are wacko cheap sometimes aren't
they yeah they're crazy but this is the
maddest thing so while you're driving
along uh in the train while you're
riding along inside of the train
especially on an underground
all of the opportunity for you to see
billboards or have advertisements sent
to you they're limited to those tiny
little sort of landscape things that are
above there's you're trying to find the
map and instead you're looking at an
advert for insurance or whatever what
they have in rome
they've mounted projectors onto the
outside of the train that project
adverts onto the inside of the moving
wall
as you go along so you look outside and
you see this advert and obviously the
projector can move and it's not just a
static thing and then as you arrive at
the next station the projector turns off
people get on you get back into darkness
you hit another wall the projector turns
back on it's a different advert so good
that is actually given that the
alternative is looking at a wall
you know if you started projecting over
building walls and projecting over views
of the thames valley i get a bit pissed
off about it but actually given that the
alternative is looking at a dark wall i
think that's actually advertising
performing a mild public service
i would agree what do you think about
insulate britain's
campaign oh crikey um
yeah
i have to say that there is often a
problem with perfectly well-intentioned
movements okay
i've very interestingly taken
environmentalism by the way which is i
think there's a 20 chance that nigel
lawson's right
and that actually um uh you know the the
anthropogenic climate change through
carbon emissions
may be a scientific mistake and a form
of collective insanity okay 20 chance i
think he's right because we you know we
do see that you know collective insanity
manifested in institutional decision
making all the time
all the time emperor's new clothes on
the other hand my question is slightly
different even if we're wrong
is it necessarily a bad thing to treat
carbon reduction as a heuristic to
improve the quality of life on the
planet
so in other words you know electric cars
may actually benefit humanity as much
through being quiet
okay think about people who live on a
busy road okay they i mean actually the
the stress created through noise so it
might be i'll give you an example of
this okay i think most people who think
they're gluten intolerant are actually
full of [ __ ] okay
um
don't get me wrong okay there are people
with celiac disease it's a serious
condition but i think for every person
who actually is gluten intolerant there
are four people who think they are and
similarly with lactose intolerance okay
among westerners not i mean it's more
common in different genetic populations
on the other hand
people who give up lactose and gluten do
feel better
or claim to now a even if that's purely
placebo effect you know what the hell
who cares if it makes you feel better
who cares secondly it may be that
following the heuristic of don't eat
gluten
causes them to feel better for some
completely unrelated reason which is
actually nothing to do with gluten but
the fact that they don't digest wheat
very well or they you know they don't
digest something else very well
it may be just a useful dietary
heuristic which improves your gut health
for reasons entirely tangential to the
reason you state what this is like so
one argument about carbon reduction is
even if nigel lawson's right that
doesn't necessarily mean that carbon
reduction isn't a useful heuristic by
which to act yeah the reasoning can
perhaps be wrong but you can still
arrive at a conclusion which is correct
i had an argument with stephen pinker
about this miasma theory wasn't actually
true okay you know german theory is a
much better theory of disease but my
asthma theory led to beneficial
consequences like you know the funding
of sewerage waste management area very
well ventilated hospitals with big
windows
which it turns out were good things to
do even if we were doing them for the
wrong reasons well this is the same as
the porcupines don't throw their quills
myth right the fact that if you treat us
so if you porcupines for a long time it
was told that porcupines could throw
their quills at you that they were
actually
some sort of archery archery animal that
was actually able to do that now that
would be [ __ ] cool it would be
awesome imagine that
but they can't
so porcupines cannot because otherwise
porcupine darts would have been a
flaming killer sport that would have
been amazing yeah you had to hold it and
then squeeze it and then you can
try and aim it yeah exactly
okay
um but the
type of behavior that the belief the
erroneous belief the incorrect belief
that porcupines throw their coils the
type of behavior that that engenders
is optimal
because you need probably more of a
degree of freedom than you think from
the porcupine and it's exactly the same
as um why jewish people don't eat pork
now
there's a sacred animal and blah blah
blah but
in olden days
pigs were very difficult to keep clean
they have a higher number of parasites
they have a higher number of uh germs
within the meat they're quite often
instrumental in the transmission cross
species transmission from birds to
humans as well okay so i mean all of
these are the reasons ducks in proximity
with pigs for example there's a greater
risk of kind of avian
clues nightmare yeah so
both of those things are
um
what one's one's i guess like a cultural
artifact and the other one is an
outright myth but it's encouraged a
particular group of people to behave in
a way which is optimal for them despite
the fact that the reasoning behind that
was a little bit more kind of
so i wrote a piece of the spectator
about this saying that the telling your
children that if you tread on the cracks
in the pavement you might be eaten by
bears which a
okay
there's a poem i think it's a little
thing which you have to watch out for
the bears because they catch children
who tread the cracks of the paper now
children are much more frightened of
bears than they are of traffic because
they've had a million years of evolution
to warm them off wild animals
what this does now there is no
scientific evidence of any correlation
between walking on pavement cracks and
the risk of bear attack okay
but what it does do is it encourages the
children to keep an eye on where they're
putting their feet which stops them
tripping over i don't know if you've had
very young children but they are prone
to getting distracted and falling flat
and they do a face palm you know they
they kind of fall flat on their faces
but secondly it means they stay on the
pavement and they don't wander off onto
the road
because by adhering strictly to stepping
within the cracks you will as a
byproduct of that belief you will adopt
a more transport
safe behavior it's this
sort of thing that's basically
impossible to mandate
yeah
so so this is what you might call
heuristic it's actually heuristic
behavior and there are there are lots of
cases where heuristics are arguably you
know social norms and because we're
noting that the greek for law is
okay i don't know i don't think that's
the origin of norm but namos means both
custom and law
the word can mean those two things and
so the creation of socially beneficial
customs
which eventually then get formalized as
laws
doesn't necessarily require
reasoning it simply requires an
empirical measurement of the benefit of
following that belief
so you know a belief in an omniscient
god is probably a pretty good way of
keeping people well behaved
okay
you know
clearly i mean you know i mean you know
if you think about it they're all kinds
of behaviors um
uh
which
would be you know bad you know which
from a purely utilitarian stance would
be completely harmless but it would be
better if people didn't indulge in them
yeah it's strange i i wonder
a lot about this the fact that there's a
level of virtue or honesty or integrity
that kind of almost holds advertising
back in this situation let's say that
you need to tell children
that there's a bear if they step on the
cracks in the street but also there's a
degree to which you think well we're
[ __ ] lying to children here we're
making them fear bears because of where
they put their feet on the pavement and
it's only culture that can deliver this
a top-down dictatorial campaign couldn't
do this because it would just be an
outright lie
charlie says have a look at the coi
campaign charlie says which you won't
you'll be too young to remember but it
was a boy who had a friend who was a cat
who delivered sensible advice about not
talking to strangers not and telling
your mummy because bear in mind this is
the 1970s so your dad was at work and
your mum was at home but always tell
your mummy if you were going out with
strangers or going out with your friends
you know uh tell your mummy where you
are going and charlie were going
okay i was a cartoon character just to
be clear and and then the child would
translate for the benefit of the earth
charlie says that you should always tell
your
mummy now that was the use of an animal
to impart good advice
now you know if we get absolutely
literal about this you know why on earth
would you have the advice delivered by a
cat
rather than by you know well the green
cross code was a hedgehog for years
wasn't it
uh you had hold on you you had no
there's a very bad weasel wasn't there
hold on let me get this right
there was a weasel
that was bad and there was a squirrel
that was good
so that was a different one that wasn't
charlie says that was a thing with a
squirrel
sophie
what was that squirrel that used to give
you advice about crossing the road tufty
tufty now that wasn't that tufty wasn't
actually a ci campaign it was funded by
the royal society for the prevention of
accidents i think
um but it was a very very useful
campaign where again you had a squirrel
and then the weasel which was a badly
behaved criminal thing uh would always
ignore the advice and end up getting run
over by a truck or sent to hospital or
whatever um and um it was it was quite
weasel-ish i mean you know it was
probably a bit unfair to weasels but um
that kind of thing is interesting
because the assumption is as adults of
course we don't need any of that stuff
we just respond to facts but as to be
honest okay the most boring finding in
advertising okay
which is so banal that i can't stand
there as kind of oxbridge graduate in
front of a bunch of clients and even
utter this fact despite the fact that it
is completely true
is that basically advertising that
features animals particularly i suspect
in the uk advertising that features
animals is more effective than
advertising that doesn't feature animals
now you know the you know
bmp under the glorious days of john
webster and the hofmeister bear and the
cresta bear and the uh
and the dog
uh tonto i think it was in john smith's
okay
i mean john john webster actually said
my question is not does the ad have legs
does the campaign have legs it's does it
have four legs and a tail
but it's almost such a banal finding
that if i had to stand up in front of a
bunch of people from png and go why
don't we put an animal in this i'd feel
like a complete idiot but it works
there's a family guy episode where
stewie the baby is going shopping with
lois the mother and he's being pushed
along in the uh in the trolley and he
sat there and she needs to get uh
aluminum foil they call it also why is
why why is americans removed one of the
eyes from aluminium
there's something even weirder about
that which is the british used to
pronounce or spell it differently in
some way as well so i'll try and find
out i'll go and do the research after
this is over aluminum foil pushing along
and he starts mocking the fact that on
the side of one of these aluminum foils
there's a tiger he says look at this
tiger what's the tiger doing an aluminum
foil it's pointless and then his mother
goes to pick up the one that doesn't
have the tiger and he goes no no i want
the one that's got the tiger on tiger
yeah precisely so i want to talk about
you is kind of a walking id isn't it
correct correct yes yeah yeah yeah he's
just exposition throughout the entire
thing
absolutely brilliant yeah
i want to talk about some of the things
why is he got a british accent is that
just because i'm not sure i think it's
because there's a low-key hint at the
fact that he's gay and he that
effeminate nature maybe americans think
that brits are a bit effeminate but
there's also the limey brit as well
isn't that there's the sort of slimy
limey version but then there's maybe the
i don't know
it's fascinating isn't it i i mean it
may just be because the guy who does the
voice loves doing it that nails it yeah
and then you're locked in that's that's
the mad thing about when you start a tv
show or anything like
cartoons a good example you begin a
cartoon you do a pilot you put it out
there and you think right well this is
this is the way that it's going to be
and we'll we'll just have a go and
hopefully we'll get signed
13 seasons and 200 episodes later and
all of those creative decisions that you
and your mates made when you had no idea
what you were doing you're locked into
those shy of killing some poor
unfortunate bastard off
yeah
absolutely fascinating
i was talking to john cleese about how
they came up with monty python and they
literally went in to see some guy at the
bbc
and um
he'd say so this this sort of comedy
series you know is it going to feature
sketches and they kind of look at each
other and go is it going to feature
sketches yeah yeah i think we might have
some sketches
and genuinely of course they haven't
they haven't got a clue what they're
doing and of course this being the bbc
in 1970 or 60 whatever it was
they said we'll just go away and make 10
episodes here's the money and let's go
and see what happens
and in a weird way because they didn't
know what they were doing they created
something completely unique and
distinctive if they'd gone in with a
clean format in mind
it wouldn't have had any of the
delicious because it was unlike and i
remember this as a kid it was unlike any
other television you ever watched
you know
you know the bizarre segways the you
know you know everything about it the
the fast-pacedness
you know uh
you know extraordinary kind of animated
sequences that would suddenly
interpolate themselves in between
sketches and it was utterly transfixing
in the same way i think that curb your
enthusiasm the fact that it's plotted
but not scripted
there's something about curb your
enthusiasm which means that even when
it's not being funny which is
comparatively rare it's still very
watchable
because there are elements to the whole
thing which somehow seem
completely fresh there's a kind of
verity to the dialogue and so forth
which i don't i don't think you could
write are you familiar with the thick of
it amanda yanucci's thing yeah
extraordinary fan of that glorious one
of the best british in fact i would say
i would go as far as to say it's got
it's worthy of the black adder title of
the modern era you know it was the 2010s
black adder um
i don't know whether you knew this but i
read that they filmed every scene a
minimum of twice
so they filmed one perfectly on script
and they filmed another where the actors
were permitted to ad-lib as much as they
wanted and they ended up using a really
high proportion of the number of ones
where they actually went off script and
there's a really good do you remember
when
um one of the guys is being asked to
make a coffee and as he's walking away
he throws a ball at him and he turns
around and says you're getting a cough
wee it's coffee with wee in it and that
scene was shot 30 times and he did a new
version each time 30 different takes of
him turning around and they just decided
to go for coffee coffee with we in it
because
stewart lee talks about this very
interestingly so one of the reasons why
stand-up people kind of rehearse is they
will dick around
with
and the person who first spoke about
this in comedy that it's so execution
dependent okay
and uh the first person i remember
hearing this from uh was let me get this
right um oh yeah it was douglas adams
and douglas adams used to read sentences
and paragraphs of pg woodhouse and try
and disentangle what it was about the
precise word order that made them funny
okay and then subsequently reading about
stand-up comics what they will do i
think there was you know gary gary
lineker blah blah blah blah blah like a
velvet owl it was a little analogy that
lee used and he he was tweaking
different versions of velvet owl
in every single performance both to find
out what amused the audience the most
but also actually to find out what
amused him the most
because there's a kind of recursive
um
stochastic
thing yeah yeah it's an iterative thing
where you don't quite know what's funny
until you've found it
and you notice that that you know you
can end if you write a piece you know
which is supposed to be funny of you
know 500 words you'll particularly dick
around with the last sentence about 47
different times and you can't explain
what it is that makes the last sentence
right but you know when you've got that
you couldn't you can't get there in
advance you can't say the way to write a
last sentence is this and there's
something about the cadence that we
understand instinctively that makes it
funny and a proper the last line of body
copy in advertising would be the same
the last sentence you know where you
traditionally leap back to the first
paragraph to create a kind of closed
system are people
ruling that as well is the peak end rule
contributing to that
so instinctively we kind of feel uh how
something ends uh has a disproportionate
effect on its potency as we would do if
we were making a speech
you know so you wouldn't just come up
with a banal thing you've got to end
your talk on a sentence that is kind of
semi-quotable or pithy and by the way
that advertising thing of looping back
to the beginning of the body copy was a
bit of an overused trope to be
absolutely honest i mean quite a few
very good copywriters said no no no when
it's the right place to end just end it
there you don't always have to refer
back to the beginning
what
what have you become an evangelist for
recently because we spoke a couple of
years ago and we talked about an air
fryer but since then i've heard you talk
about a glass-sided toaster a japanese
toilet and having two dishwashers
yeah i think there is a certain category
of technology which is
it's not self-explanatory but it's
self-revelatory which is you know once
driven forever smitten to borrow that
line from foxhall
um and i think the electric car is one
such thing which is that it's difficult
to persuade mobile phones with another
multi-channel television
the internet now you know i spent a
large part of the late 1990s working in
an advertising agency basically writing
to be bt customers and saying it might
be a good idea to pay to have internet
access at home
okay
now it's ridiculous now okay right okay
i mean you know if you moved into a
house there was no wi-fi you just go
okay this is a [ __ ] non-starter right
okay i mean you know nearly everybody
under the age of actually 80 would okay
but back then you have to persuade
people
now i don't think there are many other
people who change broadband provider i
don't think there are many people who
actually
revert okay i don't you know i i had
friends who are very very late rich
friends by the way who are very late to
get a mobile phone because they just
didn't like the idea
now eventually they get a mobile phone
and once they've had a mobile phone you
never go back and actually the car
itself fascinatingly there's a very good
article in edge by a guy who's an expert
in adaptive preference formation who
made the point that nobody wanted a car
but once actually if if the car had
never been invented we'd all whizz
around on trains and buses thinking this
was perfectly acceptable okay
once you've experienced car ownership
your bar and expectation for personal
autonomy
ratchets up by about 70 percent to a
point where nobody who has ever it
a lot of young people in london okay you
go no you don't need to own a car
now one of the reasons they're so
anti-car is that they've never owned one
in the same way that you know
um
you know surprisingly you know what
often happens is anybody who's been
vaccinated is not an anti-vaxxer okay so
it's one of those strange things and
actually is the proportion of the
population gets vaccinated goes up the
number of anti-vaxxers goes down
so there is a kind of collective herd
mentality that seems to go on with these
opinions talk to me about this
glass-sided toaster and so the
glass-sided toaster particularly good if
you if you toast a lot of different
things either different breads or
crumpets morning goods muffins whatever
it is you toast
because of course uh it's difficult to
know what the right setting is in
advance
for
every single
toastable
product you put into the toaster and so
the great thing with a glass-sided
toaster is you can if in doubt you put
it on eight
okay you bang the toaster on and then
you look at it and when it reaches a
point where it looks kind of just at the
right level of toastiness just that as
what thomas hardy would have saw in
brownment once it's reached the uh the
op the optimal level of enronment
then you hit eject
that's such a good idea why the two
dishwashers thing i'm gonna need
explaining to me as well ah okay so i'll
explain that which is that if you do
have two dishwashers and this is a bit
of a bone of contention with my wife
because we're having the kitchen redone
and she doesn't want two dishwashers
because she's a bloody luddite and she
said you know
okay
but you never have to unload your
dishwasher so you don't lose any storage
space because what it is is you have a
dirty dishwasher okay
and you have a clean dishwasher you
retrieve plates from the clean
dishwasher use them put them in the
dirty dishwasher eventually the clean
dishwasher is empty the dirty dishwasher
is full
you turn on the dirty dishwasher and
then you reverse the process that
becomes the clean dishwasher and so you
don't have to unload your dishwasher and
put things because the problem with the
dishwasher is you've got to empty the
dishwasher before you can put dirty
things in
okay and that's a pain in the ass
because you have to put things in
cupboards
okay
before you can start putting dirty
plates back in the dishwasher now with
two dishwashers that process doesn't
happen
and it takes quite a bit of it takes a
certain understanding of logistics and
understanding of complexity theory to
grasp that principle because it's not
intuitively obvious
do you think that they'll end up making
purpose-built uh two-segment kind of
like bunk beds dishwashers you could get
one that would come in and then you
could even have perhaps a wall between
them that you could slide things
backward and forward well there there is
interestingly a fisher and pikel
dishwasher made in new zealand which has
two drawers and you can put them on
separately
probably not enough size though eh
because you want to be able to have a
full dishwasher load
well i i kind of agree with you they
they're also of course popular um
someone thought i was absolutely bonkers
when i said this they had a fisheries
dishwasher and i said very popular with
orthodox jews
and they thought i was making some sort
of weird racist point and got really
upset no no it's because if you're
actually a devout jew you have to keep
your crockery separate
so it's stuff that's stuff that touches
dairy and stuff that touches meat has to
be entirely separate no so the fish
dishwasher which allows you to wash them
separately
and
and somebody not realizing this thing
about jewish dietary law looked at me as
if i was kind of like some sort of
xenophobe yeah weird zenophobe but i
said no no no no no it's a religious
prescription
i learned this about um about ben
shapiro who's a jew and their sabbath i
think is is it friday sunset friday sun
down to saturday sundown yeah precisely
and he's not allowed to use anything
electric so he can't touch anything
electric during that time
uh it's slightly complicated you can
have things on timers yes but so that's
what he's got he's got smart lights
around his house that are pre-programmed
and that to me i don't get me wrong i
think that ben should be allowed to
light his house as he wishes but i'm not
sure that that's in the spirit
of the dog
i mean the other thing you can have is a
sabbath guy
and a sabbath guy is someone who lives
who's not jewish
um oh god they're a light turner
honorary so yeah yeah
i mean i remember when i was at
university it was late
and
uh they closed the
door to the college at about i can't
remember what it was midnight or
something okay and there was a little
door and then they locked the little
door at the it's called a judas door
actually they locked the judas door
sometime like midnight
and we were there saturday night and
there was this huge banging on the door
and the italian guy who was the porter
said jews
okay and of course they couldn't ring
the bell but they could knock on the
door oh that's so funny and the reason
is of course electricity didn't exist
but it's deemed to be making fire
and so if you flick a switch
it's there's also a weird thing about
keys about locking your house because i
spoke to a manchester police officer
who did quite a lot of police work with
the orthodox community in manchester
and you can wear keys but you can't
carry them
on the sabbath
and so there's some sort of thing which
is if you have a kind of key chain
um that's considered okay whereas put
putting them in your pocket loose so
lanyard or something might just accept
there's some sort of but they would
quite often get people you would quite
sheet off and quite often be patrolling
the area and people will come in and say
uh you know could you turn my cooker on
for me wow
that's crazy i didn't know
i think i think that question of the
spirit of the thing is an interesting
question because i've always thought
that's a little you know having an
elevator that goes up and down
if you go to an israeli hotel
okay quite often on the sabbath the
elevator is programmed just to stop at
every floor so no one needs to push a
button
now
uh yeah there's a bit of me that goes
that's kind of cheating mate
um but i i think the point is that there
is a certain doc there's a certain kind
of jewish restriction which you obey it
and there is no reason
the argument is and i can't remember
what the hebrew phrase is but it's a law
for which there is no reason you simply
have to follow this
and the argument they made about this
particular kind of law is that if you
provide a reason okay
people will always look for reasons to
get rid of the law
they'll say ah but it doesn't apply
because you know uh it doesn't you know
the you know the prescription on pork
doesn't apply because um now we have
high standards of hygiene in a factory
so if you've given a reason saying that
this is unclean so in order to have
these successful heuristic rules
they need to be capable of being
chesterton's fences in other words
something you obey without knowing why
you were bad i mean that's every
yeah that's every parent of a teenager
that's their rule decree
why can't i go out tonight because i
said so that's the it's because there is
no coming back to that because i said so
is this bulletproof of a an argument as
you're going to find
and so actually having those um
i mean there's a huge amount of chest
and fence stuff in for example jewish
and muslim
uh law
which is very chestertonian in the sense
that
just because you don't know what it's
for
doesn't mean you should just disregard
it
because the person who instigated it may
have had a good reason there's a hell of
a lot of good stuff in the quran about
what to do if there's a plague
for example jewish muslim
very very rapid burying of bodies
okay
it you know has very positive hygiene
effects
so during the crimean war interestingly
you had effectively christians fighting
turks
and the muslims were absolutely
assiduous about burying the dead
and the christians weren't
and as a result
from decomposition and decomposing
bodies the disease was a much much
greater uh cause of loss of life on the
part of the
uh i think i haven't got this right i'm
probably talking historical bollocks
here but but um similarly
um the belief in revenants is why um
cemeteries tend to be built outside
towns the belief that the souls of the
dead would rise up and haunt you totally
irrational belief on the other hand
building cemeteries outside towns is
pretty good from a public health point
of view yeah particularly if you have to
deal with a water supply or you know
anything of that kind do you know where
the word quarantine comes from
40 days yes quaranta yes i learned that
while i was in florence uh a couple of
weeks ago that's probably a heuristic
rule which is that by and large
anything that's going to manifest itself
will manifest itself in that period yeah
it's either you're either dead or you're
okay in the space
we could argue okay it was kind of
i guess in in in they eventually in
covid they brought it down to about what
was it ten days i think wasn't it
eventually yeah
that uh and by the way that was
probabilistic i think that there were a
certain number of people who manifested
symptoms ten days more than ten days
after they were infected but what you
were doing was effectively making a
trade-off then between uh you know total
inconvenience yep and you know so it
couldn't have been the last 40 days
because the compliance would have been
so low that it might as well have been
yeah
well that's a very interesting question
actually which i often raise about this
which is that when you design a rule
you it's very rare that you can design a
rule on purely scientific grounds
without factoring in behavioral factors
so 40 days in a hotel room would be so
much to ask your people that um what
about happened in melbourne wasn't it is
the hotel security started having sex
with the guests no way
no there was a huge outbreak in victoria
and the reason was that people at the
quarantined hotels were so goddamn bored
they started having sex with the people
who are there to provide security
amazing
that was so funny
oh my god and the joke was why why is
australia like the spice girls because
victoria has to spoil it for everyone
else
but but the interesting thing is let's
say let's say you know and i think they
knew this okay six or eight months ago
okay
outdoor non-dense social
encounters are highly unlikely to lead
to transmission okay so i said outdoor
and non-dense i don't mean a football
crowd but i mean people a garden a
buckingham palace garden party with
reasonable social distancing is very
unlikely to lead to transmission
so a completely rational person would
say okay we'll allow outdoor social
events
now
the problem there is you've got to
factor in the behavioral component as
well as the scientific component which
is this
outdoor event outdoor socializing tends
to lead to indoor socializing because
you meet in the afternoon it gets cold
in the early evening a few people move
into the conservatory they leave the
door open you know the patio heaters run
out of gas the next thing you know is
there 10 people in the conservatory then
they close the door because it's getting
a bit nippy then four people use the loo
then they go into the kitchen and they
have a row about brexit and before you
know you've had a super spreading event
now if that sounds fanciful that's
exactly what happened at the white house
right they had a
bloody session in the rose garden i
think nobody who only attended the rose
garden event got infected they all went
back into that orangery thing
whatever it's called you know that kind
of you know you know off the path you
can't really reverse the white house
having a patio but you know what i mean
and they went into that thing with the
curvy windows and that's when the
transmission happened and so you can't
just say you have to be an empiricist
you can't just be a kind of reductionist
when you design legislation
what are your thoughts around the
communications that we've seen to do
with vaccines
um the um
oh crikey um bloody hell
um uh
one really interesting thing okay
there's been to be honest i mean in the
uk i'm i'm pretty impressed with my
fellow brits they're pretty sane but in
fairness as more and more people get
vaccinated the hesitancy or decreases
even in the unvaccinated
i'm not totally hostile to anti-vaxxers
by which i mean people who are opposed
to vaccinating um the very young
because
there is a case to be made that actually
you know the cost benefit analysis might
not pay off uh old people who refuse to
be vaccinated are just being
irresponsible uh middle-aged people look
mate you know you kind of have a duty to
you know
to your fellow man here auntie masters
strike me struck me as completely
bonkers because it was to me even if the
thing didn't work it was a mild courtesy
to my fellow man you know i saw the mask
wearing as you know rather like the
reason i tend to wear underpants and
trousers when i go out which is that
even if it would be more convenient for
me to walk around naked i i'm conscious
of the fact that it might cause distress
to other people
so you know and also i love the the
comment of the comedian i can never
remember his name he's always on um
uh bill bailey i said people said you
know wearing a mask you know they're
making us wear masks it's like the nazis
because that's right isn't it because he
said that's what the nazis are chiefly
famous for imposing mild inconveniences
i think all right okay
my view was the cost of wearing a mask
was so trivial
one or two caveats there
um
i'm not totally comfortable with
mandating masts all the time out of
doors
for a very strange reason
which is i did find that wearing a mask
slightly disoriented me when i was
crossing a busy road i have no idea why
that is
um but there were certain aspects to it
but indoor mask wearing and mask wearing
in any kind of densely populated area
struck me as simply something which even
if i didn't believe in it i'd be happy
to go along with that of just you know
courtesy to my fellow man now one very
important point with anti-vaxxing
which i was i i i had theorized about
this
but had never written about it because i
thought it was maybe too stupid a point
to make
but somebody else also theorized it and
went to the intelligent lengths of
actually investigating it and that's the
fear of needles played a bigger part in
anti-vaxxing than we let on because
about a significant double digit
percentage of people are really
frightened of needles okay i'm not not
bothered i've got a friend who might
faint if you injected him with a needle
you know he was actually had a policy
for the liberal democrats he's an oxford
history graduate right he's not some
wacko but
the phobias are very strange they're
very strange things
if i said to you because of some
peculiar medical reason that the
injection the covet vaccine injection
had to be given into your eyeball
i think you'd rapidly go around
you know looking for reasons not to get
vaccinated i mean you know i i you know
i think it's now for people who have a
real phobia of needles
the idea of being injected in the arm is
equivalently distressing as it would be
to you or me after all i know you may be
frightened of needles but do you or me
being injected in the eye i think it's
fair to say would give me the [ __ ]
heebie-jeebies yeah it's just
differences in uh
differences in degree not differences in
kinds right just risk tolerance here so
one interesting thing is quite some of
those people may have been engaging in
what you might call
um motivated reasoning
so they were frightened of getting
injected but they didn't want to say
this so they contrived they
they reverse engineered a whole load of
reasons not to get vaccinated which were
enough now i don't think that explains
the whole anti-vax movement but it's a
relevant sector and one of the things
they said is if you told people you can
get vaccinated in private you can get
vaccinated lying down so if you do faint
you don't crash onto the floor
um and the other another thing you might
want to do is you might want to offer
those people a very very rapid fact
so if you if you went to someone who's
frightened of needles right and you said
uh do you want to come in now and get
vaccinated they might go [ __ ] it out and
get it over with yes yes if you because
the anticipation for so long is where
their
yeah their discomfort is going to come
from you know i've got friends who
basically you know well i'll give you
the classic example of where i
understand this is public speaking
because i do a lot of it right you've
got to do a lot of it because if you
only do a bit of it it's too frightening
and i know people totally intelligent
people who if they have to give a speech
like a best man speech or a business
speech in front of a hundred people
four weeks away
they have to spend four weeks [ __ ]
themselves okay literally four weeks i
noticed when i started flying on
business because of course a lot of
people who fly business don't really
want to fly but their boss has told them
they've got to go to frankfurt i notice
in the business class compartment of
planes a significant minority of people
are clutching the armrest on takeoff
you know it's white knuckle [ __ ] so one
of the interesting things you could do
with people who are frightened of
getting injected is just say come in
right now and get injected you know or
there's a walk-on by thing because if
you actually had an appointment for them
three weeks hence they'd have to put up
with three weeks of total anxiety
and that might have been a factor in in
emotional decision making which we
didn't we didn't actually think about
did you know i don't know if this story
is true and i'm going to stress test it
on you
the original by the way on the fear of
things like that i had a friend
who did medicine at cambridge
and on about day 10 you go into the
dissecting room it's your first year
medical student there are a lot of
corpses right laid out on tables and
you've got to get a scalpel you've got
to start putting into bits right
now bear in mind these people have spent
six years of their life getting into
cambridge to read medicine okay right
and apparently on that first day
you know you'll get i don't know 300
medical students or whatever in the
first year medical students i don't know
how many there are but it'll be
something like 200 300. and about two or
three of them will just go [ __ ] this
right not for me not for me
yeah and they'll go and read law or you
know something like that so that's like
a hazing ritual to select out the people
that are never going to be able to do
this
it's a really really interesting
question about that because if you're
too squeamish to do that maybe you just
can't be a doctor cut your [ __ ]
losses after 10 days mate it's fine yeah
yeah cut your losses yeah yeah um did
you know about this is the original
reason
that a head on top of a beer a pint of
beer that that was there and it was seen
as scum originally no that's coffee not
beer is it coffee oh yes it's it's
kramer kramer that's it yes
so in other words it was it was
considered scum and it was the gadget
machine post-war gadget machine produced
this stuff
and instead of getting rid of it because
an espresso previously pre-war italian
espresso was just pure and black
they they effectively rebranded it as
kramer and something else has occurred
to me which has done that okay are you
familiar with the how long have you how
long since you've been in the uk
uh week
oh so well you'll have to tell me why
you're in austin anyway fantastic okay
are you familiar with the m s cheddar
brand cornish cruncher
[Laughter]
it's a mature cheddar brand and it's
called cornish cruncher now what's very
clever about that right
is that when you make mature cheddar
particularly super mature cheddar the
process of maturation causes salt
crystals to form within the cheese
and so
you know someone who just called it
cornish mature would run the risk that
people go what are these weird lumps
doing in my cheese
but by calling it cornish cruncher you
turn a bug into a feature
that's so good so it's really really
clever really really clever thing to do
i love that that's what what how i don't
know how you would it's like advertising
brazilian jiu jitsu so you've taken
something which was a byproduct that
shouldn't have been there and turned it
into something which is now an actual
attribute of the product the most
glorious thing of all i might actually
go there this evening i'm almost tempted
is the german kebab
and i couldn't get my head around this
at all it's a huge thing in in in
britain the um the the german kebab
house
okay
and i just think what the [ __ ] hell
of the germans got contributed to the
kebab you know why would i go to now
it's interesting because of course
germany has a turkish population of
about six million
the kebab world it's like the indian
restaurant world in britain okay the
kebab world in germany because their
ethnic food is turkish whereas ours is
largely you know indian as god intended
okay and i was i was saying to someone
on the other day which is that my own
particular pantheon of food
all indian restaurants have an automatic
michelin star you know it's like all all
buildings built before 1700 are
automatically grade two and all indian
restaurants have a great have a michelin
star in my in my particular book okay
because even if it's bad it's still
better than anything else right
okay but but anyway in germany it's it's
the kebab that they're kebab wars it's
hugely competitive okay and you
literally have people putting fresh
heads of lettuce in the window of their
shop to show how fresh the salad is
and so this hyper competition in the
church
in german and since their auto industry
might be stuffed by the electric car
it's good they've got another export
industry waiting in the wings
so so the german concern i might
actually go this evening and tool into
bromley and try one of these things so
i've never had one i think i did i think
i got treated to one the last time i
came to london but it was just
someone said you just want to get a
kebab and i thought it's three in the
afternoon this is a we're 12 hours too
early and i haven't had six pipes yeah
precisely i've i haven't i haven't
fought anyone this evening i haven't
haven't lost my keys and had an argument
with the misses so yeah it's um
that's so strange to think about the
fact that you associate a particular
type of food with the time of the day
and not just because of the effect it
has on you so for instance if you have a
big pizza for lunch you're going to be
sleepy for the rest of the day no one's
no one's serving a big pizza at lunch
ahead of a long conference where
everyone's in a warm room
you can game that system by the way next
time you're in central london
go and find a michelin-starred indian
restaurant
now as i said all indian restaurants
have a michelin star but go and find one
with a real mesh star okay
and
first of all you'll be able to get in
okay at lunch time this is the this is
the big thing
secondly they will have a lunchtime set
menu
which is like
24.95 okay you spend that at pizza
express it's the biggest bargain in the
world it's all because most people
associate indian food with the evening
and i also suspect it's because out of
any group of four people there'll always
be one worse you guys
eat indian food for lunch i had a boss i
lost all respect for them boss you said
you don't need indian food at lunch time
i said well 1.4 billion indians seem to
manage okay mate
and um so i love eating indian food at
lunchtime i'm sure it's fantastic but
you will get the best bar i mean you
you're getting world-class food there
for kind of pizza money pennies on the
dollar yeah
i think this was one of your tweets from
the other day one reason political
polarization tends to be confined to the
young and stupid is this anyone over 35
possessed of any observational mouse has
noticed that there is no correlation
between political allegiance and basic
decency as a human being yeah by the way
a lot of people misinterpreted that and
thought i meant young and also stupid
whereas i meant and or stupid so i'm
just going to qualify that this is the
problem with twitter you don't have
quite the space to necessarily make
clear and also the great mistake you
understand what you're writing and other
and on twitter because people willfully
misunderstand what you're saying which
is the worst problem of all so you have
this inadequate mode of expression
combined with willful misunderstanding
which leads to these kind of ridiculous
spats okay
and so
the point i'm making is that yeah i
would argue that this moralization of
political opinion if you are reasonably
astute
um or you know you're reasonably a
student particularly if you're over 40
years old you do realize that there are
nice left-wing people and
nice right-wing people and they're
horrible left-wing people and horrible
right-wing people and that political
allegiance is not really a suitable
enough um
shiver left on which to actually judge
people's moral character i i still think
that's a fair point i mean
you know there are certain behaviors for
example uh where you know certain
behaviors which you would think would be
right wing
which some which which just as often
crop up in the left like you know
extreme stinginess for example
you know you know real stinginess is is
doesn't really you'd think that might be
a bit of a right wing vice but actually
you find it just as often than people on
the left um and
okay
people were then going oh but you know
you know but actually you know they spit
what about the extreme right and the
extreme left well fair point but they
tend to be pretty nasty on either you
know in either direction
um for nasty for different reasons but
still nasty i think the average age at
the moment it might be in the uk i think
it is in the uk is 20.
the average age for the population in
the uk no no it's much higher than that
no
there are lots of countries where the
average age lost countries in africa
where the average age is very very young
okay but japan's japan's historically
the highest right um uh germany's quite
high or i mean uh
uh historically because germans have
fewer and fewer children and have them
also people have children later which
also skews things no no the uk tends to
be tends to be quite a has quite a large
elderly population i think what is the
median
the proper thing is not perhaps the
average age but the median age so let me
again find out what the median age is in
the uk
uk median age forty point four wow is it
i've got mine
don't worry in 2001 it was 37.9
yeah so the average age of the uk
population has been increasing
throughout this time period although
between 2014 and 2016 the median age
remained at 40. wow so
what you're saying is that if it has the
highest median age actually it's very
interesting monaco
taxation 55.4
followed by japan at 48.6
san pierre and michelong which is so
small as to be a bit silly um and then
germany 47.8 well i mean japan is
japan's completely annihilated by all of
these outliers that live to 120 years
old that's their problem yeah they also
also i suppose whether they have you you
also get these weird people who live
live at home don't you you know um so
they tend not to have children so family
formation happens later and later
combined with smaller and smaller
families
and so quite often there are three or
three things going on at the same time
we're going to see some really
interesting population demographics
aren't we over the next sort of 20 to 50
years it really does feel like we're not
going to i asked someone the other day
that seems to understand this pretty
well whether or not the world is going
to break 10 billion people and they said
they said it was touch and go about
whether or not we just glance off the
bottom of that and then start to tune
back down again
my my hunch would be actually
that there's a very good book on this
which is packed full of statistics two
good books i'll recommend to your
listeners factfulness
by hans rosling oh you thank you i was
just gonna google it and there's another
book called the great slowdown by danny
dawling who's an oxford professor of
geography who makes the point that
actually
most things in the world are either
shrinking or the speed at which they're
growing is shrinking and let me just
read out if i if i look up the great
slowdown by uh danny dawling
i will tell you what the subtitle is
because it's quite a good book it's
called slowdown sorry the end of the
great acceleration
and why it's good for the planet the
economy and our lives and dawling has an
interesting take on statistics using
these particularly peculiar graphs which
are mostly used i think only in
you know abstruse parts of mathematics
which shows that
most things are either slowing down
or they're increasing at a decreasing
rate
and um so you know the
very large families are disappearing
very very rapidly in parts of the world
like latin america where we wouldn't
necessarily have predicted it in my
childhood the only thing dawling could
find that was increasing at an
increasing rate was i think jet air
travel
which would have been effectively
because china and india have now been
entered into the domestic airline so
we've got a stake we've got a step
change there that's opened up an extra
two and a half billion people to this
that's effectively opened up i guess
it's what is it probably 50 million or
60 million people in india 60 100
million people in china maybe more who
can fly domestically on planes whereas
that would have been a tiny percentage
of the population uh you know not that
many decades ago you know india you
travel by train if you're going long
distance unless you were super rich
um
and um i mean my brother remembers going
on a long distance coach in chile in the
1990s
and he boarded this coach and was
surprised to discover it was a super
luxury coach with like reclining seats
and everything else
and he couldn't work out why this thing
you know because your vision of a latin
american coach in the 1990s was kind of
you know you'd be sharing it with some
chickens or something okay and what he
realized of course is back in 1994 to
fly internally within chile was like
super expensive
so this was effectively a business coach
if you're traveling on business between
santiago and um farmer gusto that isn't
chile isn't i'm not talking [ __ ]
here okay if you're traveling
long distance and chilly of course is
the kind of shape where quite a lot of
journeys are quite long
unless you were like the chief executive
of the business you wouldn't fly you'd
basically go by coach
um and so as a result they had these
super luxury coaches which were the
equivalent of domestic air travel in the
united states
we should have that in the uk more i
think i mean you know funnily enough um
george mombio uh has made that case that
coach travel if you could destigmatize
coach travel
i'll tell you i'll tell you a business
if anybody's listening and they want to
get in touch okay
you could even take the business even
further and put your car on a car
transporter but okay
but a bus that left london
at let's say 9 p.m
picked me up at ashford or ebb's fleet
at like 10 30
where i had a tiny little cabin
and woke up in frankfurt
right you've got the european motorway
network which is more or less empty
overnight okay certainly it'll be very
smooth you've got modern coaches which
have much much better suspension and
soundproofing and they've got toilets
and onboard entertainment and a coffee
machine okay
it's not the coach travel of my
childhood which was frankly um pretty
grim
okay so you could undoubtedly if you
could just destigmatize coach travel you
could use the failure to create a
european sleeper train network
um and actually i i would now the other
one i've always wanted is one where you
put your car on a car transporter okay
uh you you bought you bought a kind of
little cabin thing now the way you could
do it is if they're two of you you'd
share a cabin if i'm traveling on
business i'd pay double and have a cabin
to myself with a bit of a desk a bit the
way the sleeper trains work you know it
first class is the same as second you
just don't have to share
okay
and you know i would i would definitely
travel to frankfurt one way overnight
that way because i'd rather get on a
bloody coach in eb's fleet at ten
o'clock at night then have to get up at
five o'clock in the morning and then
travel to london city or something but
that's the alternative right this is
something that nobody ever thinks about
they look at the journey time and
skyscanner does this brilliantly because
they tell you the
total amount of travel time but then you
need to add on the transfers then you
need to add on the amount of time to
check in at the front end to collect
your bags at the back end the
transport and potential cost to get
yourself from where you are to the
airport and when you actually end up
loading all of this up at the end you
think [ __ ] i might as well just of
course what happened is that coach
travel tended to be
has been associated with people who
can't afford to travel any other way
because they don't own a car they can't
afford to go by train they're very price
sensitive um
you know quite often you get a fairly
high piss head propensity on a coach as
well you get that on trains as well
though trains trains are you can trains
are yeah it's okay to drink at any time
on a train if it's 10 a.m isn't that
funny people drink yeah they forget we
wouldn't go for a pint at 10 in the
morning usually you're off to a work
meeting but because you're on a train
there used to be a trade that went
effectively non-stop from glasgow to
brighton and it went through kensington
olympia so it went through that western
thing then went down to east croydon
then gatwick then brighton
i think i've got that right have i
yes yeah definitely yeah uh and anyway i
boarded it once
between i think
kensington olympia
and
gatwick because it was a convenient way
of getting together bear in mind it was
full of glaswegians who'd been on the
train for five and a half hours
basically i was a smoker back then i was
in the smoking compartment you couldn't
see the opposite window
and every time the train went over a set
of points
407 empty cans of tenant super would
crash off the table
or roll around the floor just gorging
their contents it was one of the most it
was it was kind of like hieronymus bosh
you know it was extraordinary
but i don't blame them entirely but if
you're going to sit on a train for eight
hours i mean it's not a totally crazy
way of passing the timer the only way
that you can put up with it is by
getting yourself pissed look rory
sutherland ladies and gentlemen where
can people go to pick up the new book
rory
right so you can go wherever you
normally buy books which probably means
amazon but let me go and give you it's
called transport for humans it's pete
dyson and rory sutherland are the
authors the subtitle is um are we nearly
there yet okay it's got a very nice
cover which shows the brain in the shape
of a tube map which i have to say
whoever the graphic designer was
deserves some kudos and uh it's
available i suppose i should quote the
price shouldn't i did you do this
actually did you do an audible version
of it as well
i've got to record that okay so you can
pre-order that okay
i haven't recorded the audible footage
okay well it's fairness to me okay i i i
was already in sector one weekend and
they got a massively sore throat now
it's pre-orderable on amazon it'll be
available because it comes out on the
18th right
18 1499 the kindle edition's 849 the
paperbacks 1499 and let me just brag
it's currently even though it hasn't
come out yet just on pre-orders loan on
amazon it's number one in road and
transport engineering number one in
urban and rural planning and number four
in the transportation industry category
so the only books that are beating in
the transportation industry category are
published by
the driver and vehicle standards agency
which books you need to read to pass
your driving test we're even beating all
aboard the timeless book uh all about um
uh remembering british railways so
unless it's mandated by law before you
can actually get in a car your book's
doing pretty well
so at no point did i ever think that i
would be number four in the
transportation industry books category
of amazon so i have it's one of those
strange things you know it's going to be
my best humble brag for the rest of my
life i think i was once once number four
in the transportation category on amazon
but the one i don't understand is why is
the ghosts of biggin hill by bob ogle
who's a local seven oaks historian by
the way uh and and frequent columnist
for the seven eggs chronicle not that
you'd be expected to know that why is it
in at number 29 why is that suddenly
surged why isn't he in it higher than
that that's the question that we need to
be asking yeah i know i'm beating the
ghost of big and hill anyway so you know
so take that bob you bastard
rory thank you so much for today it's a
drive anytime thanks everyone what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace